tonight you will be sending one of the
girls to the hideaway for the night as
you take their place date their guy and
sleep in their bed
whoa the savagery of getting so real on
love island I think it's exciting and
scary in the same time Tuesday's episode
kicked off with meeting the newest
Islanders Kristen and Katrina everyone's
relaxing they're comfortable so I want
to go in there I want to challenge them
and go for what I want I'm here for a
reason I am here if my love I will not
have asex and I am NOT going to be in
any drama or get physical so basically
I'm not freaking and I'm not fighting
safe to say the girls that were already
coupled up started to feel a little
anxious kind of are just a little shaken
about Kristen and Katrina coming in
things didn't get any easier as Kristen
and Katrina did a round of speed-dating
with the guys and the girls watched I'm
definitely open to experience in this
whole thing you know we all owe it to
ourselves to you know try to form the
best connections that we can to be
honest like you were someone who caught
my eye because I think you're genuinely
funny one speed-dating was over some of
the couples were forced to have awkward
conversations like Cashel and Kira are
you interested in one of them like
Katrina no not at all but you could but
you could possibly like be into
Kristen I guess I did like I want to see
her personality I loved her
chill I keep it chill and just when we
thought the tension couldn't get any
thicker Kristin and Katrina received the
same game-changing text message asking
them to send one of the girls to the
hideaway and take their place their guy
and sleep in the same bed do I feel like
I haven't kind of breakin their shell
yet so the guy I
the person that I would choose tonight
went out to be Weston et spoke with
Katrina before she arrived at the love
island Villa she opened up about the
kind of guy she's looking for Weston
listen up
if someone who's very family-oriented
someone who is funny and can take jokes
because I give a lot of jokes and
someone who is ambitious in a sense of
like very whether it's career-wise or
just the fact that he knows that one day
he is gonna be ready to settle down and
have like a family or anything like that
but I would say those are like my top
deal-breakers everything else is like
you know I can I can deal with it
[Music]